hablemos un poco sobre arterias y venas
veamos qué papel juegan en el sistema
circulatorio pero primero me gustaría
que pasaran el vídeo y reflexionarán un
poco tienen alguna idea de qué son las
venas y de qué son las arterias bueno la
idea detrás de las venas y arterias es
que en la mayoría de estos dibujos las
arterias se representan de color rojo
por eso he puesto la palabra arteria de
color rojo y las venas de color azul y
están relacionadas con la cantidad de
oxígeno que contiene así que una posible
explicación es que las arterias llevan
sangre oxigenada sangre oxigenada
mientras que las venas llevan sangre de
su oxígeno aquí la sangre contiene menos
oxígeno pero en realidad esta es una
idea equivocada porque aunque muchas
veces las arterias son las que llevan
sangre oxigenada y las venas la sangre
de su oxigenada como veremos en un
momento
es el caso como estamos hablando de
sangre oxigenada sangre de se oxigenada
y de los colores rojo y azul
es importante mencionar otra idea
errónea muchas veces se dice que la
sangre de su oxígeno se ve de color azul
la razón por la que las personas creen
eso es porque si observamos nuestra
muñeca podemos ver que las venas son de
color azul bueno se ven de color azul
cuando las vemos por fuera de la piel y
esas sin dudas son las venas pero de ahí
surge la idea equivocada de que la
sangre de 'shock' sijena da en las venas
de nuestro brazo es de color azul en
realidad la sangre de nuestras venas no
es azul sino que es sangre más oscura la
razón por la que las venas se ven de
color azul es debido a la óptica de la
luz que pasa a través de nuestra piel y
choca contra el exterior de nuestras
venas por eso no observamos el color
real de nuestra sangre pero hasta ahora
no les he dado una definición clara de
qué son las arterias y las venas voy a
tachar esto
una mejor definición nos dice que las
arterias llevan la sangre lejos del
corazón lejos del corazón y las venas
las llevan hacia el corazón hacia el
corazón aquí tenemos una imagen
amplificada del corazón para que quede
más claro aquí también podemos ver
porque la primera definición de las
arterias y las venas no siempre es
correcta imaginemos que la sangre es
bombeada hacia el exterior del corazón
cuando esto sucede la sangre pasa por la
aorta y aquí podemos ver que la aorta se
ramifica por lo que una parte de la
sangre puede ir hacia la cabeza porque
si no llega a la cabeza podemos morir y
otra parte de la sangre baja hacia el
resto de nuestro cuerpo
todo esto es sin duda sangre oxigenada
así que la sangre oxigenada fluye por
nuestro cuerpo y las arterias continúan
ramificándose una y otra vez en
conductos cada vez más pequeños hasta
que forman estas ramificaciones pequeñas
y es particularmente
en estos lugares en donde pierden mucho
del oxígeno para dárselo a los fluidos y
células que se encuentran alrededor así
que la sangre se va de su oxigenando y
aunque la sangre de su oxígeno no es
azul
generalmente se dibuja de color azul en
muchos diagramas así que lo dibujaré
también de esta forma esto ya se empieza
a convertir en nuestras venas y estos
conductos tan pequeños que conectan las
arterias con las venas en donde ocurre
gran parte de los intercambios de gas y
nutrientes a éstos se les conoce como
capilares después de pasar por los
capilares la sangre regresa al corazón
pero ahora regresa al corazón a través
de las venas entra por el atrio derecho
hacia el ventrículo derecho y eso es
bombeado hacia los pulmones aquí
encontramos la excepción a las primeras
definiciones incorrectas de arterias y
venas que habíamos visto esta de aquí es
una arteria aún cuando lleva sangre con
menos oxígeno es una
arteria porque lleva sangre hacia el
exterior del corazón pero en este caso
no la lleva hacia el resto del cuerpo
sino que la lleva hacia los pulmones por
eso se llama arteria pulmonar pulmonar
aún cuando lleva sangre de se oxigenada
entonces la sangre pasa a los pulmones y
ahí aumenta el intercambio gaseoso la
sangre es oxigenada y nuevamente regresa
al corazón entonces regresa al corazón a
través de estos conductos y aunque
llevan sangre altamente oxigenada a
estos conductos se les considera venas
porque llevan la sangre hacia el corazón
así que estas son las venas pulmonares
venas pulmonares y el ciclo se reinicia
las venas pulmonares traen la sangre
oxigenada a través del atrio izquierdo y
el ventrículo izquierdo y después eso se
bombea al resto de nuestro cuerpo a
través de la aorta para continuar con el
sistema de circulación
tenemos la circulación pulmonar que
lleva
sangre a través y desde los pulmones y
tenemos la circulación sistemática que
lleva la sangre al resto del cuerpo así
que ahora que tenemos esta distinción
general entre arterias y venas que otras
cosas interesantes conocemos bueno una
cosa para tomar en cuenta es que como
las arterias son bombeadas directamente
por el corazón hacia el resto del cuerpo
su presión es alta lo escribiré en
mayúsculas presión alta entonces si
tenemos un accidente de algún tipo que
espero que no ocurra pero si
accidentalmente se cortará una arteria
debido a la alta presión saldrían
chorros de sangre más de lo que saldría
si se cortará una vena porque muchas
veces cuando nos cortamos
accidentalmente únicamente se cortan los
capilares por ejemplo cuando nos
cortamos un dedo generalmente cortamos
una serie de capilares y por esa razón
la sangre sale muy lentamente
si las arterias tienen presión alta las
venas tienen presión baja presión baja y
una forma de pensar en esto es que la
sangre en las arterias es bombeada
directamente por el corazón pero una vez
que llega a los capilares regresa por
medio de las venas y viaja lentamente de
regreso al corazón no es bombeada
directamente entonces como en las venas
no tenemos presión alta que nos ayude a
regresar todo al corazón tenemos estas
válvulas que se aseguran de que la mayor
parte de la sangre vaya en una dirección
voy a dibujar la sangre en nuestras
venas de color rojo para que no
continuemos con la idea equivocada de
que la sangre en nuestras venas es de
color azul bien y en relación con el
hecho de que la sangre en las arterias
se encuentra a una mayor presión para
poder transportar un cierto volumen de
sangre en una cierta cantidad de tiempo
necesitamos menor volumen por eso es que
las arterias tienen menor volumen
mientras que las venas son de mayor
volumen
y para apreciar la diferencia el volumen
de la sangre en las arterias es
únicamente el 15 por ciento de todo el
volumen de sangre que tenemos en nuestro
cuerpo mientras que el volumen de sangre
en las venas esté aproximadamente el 65%
pero si se preguntan en dónde se
encuentra el resto de la sangre un 5% se
encuentra presente en los capilares 5%
en el corazón y aproximadamente un 10%
en los pulmones pero vamos a dejarlo
hasta aquí lo más importante es que las
arterias son los conductos que llevan la
sangre fuera del corazón y las venas son
los conductos que llevan la sangre de
regreso al corazón nos vemos en otro
vídeo